this is an HSE question on the normal
distributions so I've written down the
most important details of the question
on the board already because we're gonna
refer to them in a minute but I'm gonna
read out for the sake of context I'm
gonna read out the wording of the entire
questions so it's talking about a
company that manufactures white Globes
this is what it says the manufacturer's
specifications state that the expected
life of the light globes is normally
distributed with a standard deviation of
one hundred and seventy hours so I'm
using s because that's the the reference
sheets label for standard deviation
which I'm going to come back to in a
second the actual questions is what is
the main life I should probably write
that down what we're after is the mean X
bar what's the mean life in hours of
these light globes
if ninety seven point five percent of
the light globes will last up to five
thousand hours so that's this piece of
information here so we get given
standard deviation we also given that a
certain proportion of the entire light
globe population lasts this long and
what they want us to work out is what's
the average life span of these live
clothes what's x bar in this context so
we need a lot of information we need a
lot of pieces of information that go
along with this and the formula and data
set is going to help us here okay so the
first thing I would draw because this is
a question about the normal distribution
it literally says you know it's normally
distributed I'm going to draw for myself
a normal distribution and I'm going to
put some labels onto here that are going
to help we've got the middle of the
normal distribution right here and
what's relevant about the middle for us
you know this is this average which we
don't know we don't know what the value
of the average is but we do know that
whatever the average is it has a z-score
of zero that's what the middle of the
actual distribution means as I go
further and further out I get different
proportions of this population and the
reason why that's an
one to me is because this critical piece
of information here in 97.5% it must be
linked to how much of this population am
i capturing based on how many standard
deviations I am from the mean which is
another way of saying like what what
Zedd scores will give me this proportion
okay so for instance just as a bit of
revision if you have a look at Dead
scores between negative one and one so
if you go one standard deviation away
I'll just I'll stay in black for them
how much of the population have you
captured well if you have a look at the
formula data it tells you that this
section in here is 68% though the exact
wording of the formula datasheet says
approximately 68% of scores have
z-scores between negative 1 and 1 now
68% is clearly too small for the actual
figure that we're interested in here but
keep in mind 68% is just inside here
within one standard deviation this
wording here says that whatever
percentage lasts up to five thousand
hours so what that would mean is it also
includes all of these down here up to
5,000 hours includes some died of a
light globe that lasts like three hours
right that's up to 5,000 hours so
therefore I also need to include
everyone over here so if I went right
like the least the the shortest amount
of lifespan for a light Club down here
okay this is the minimum range everyone
from here to here lasts up to whatever
the amount of hours this score here is
okay and what I'm going to do is because
68% is clearly too small here I'm gonna
go one more standard deviation out if I
go to stay of deviations away then the
foliage outer sheet tells me that this
space in here now I am going to need
another color this space in here
represents approximately 95% of the
population or of the likelihoods I guess
I should say a population of like load
now 95% still isn't our 97.5%
okay but you know that you can't go any
further you know you can't go to our
three z-scores away because when you
have a look at the formula data sheet it
reminds you that if you go three
z-scores away three standard deviations
away I should say you get ninety-nine
point seven percent which is too much
you've gone past what this amount should
be so this is where I'm going to pause
where does the extra or the missing 2.5
percent come from well recall what
you've got here is you've got a minimum
you've also got a maximum somewhere up
here if what I have colored in orange is
95% then you also have these little
other sections here and here which are
everyone else right the really really
unusual people the really above-average
light globes and the really below
average light globes now how much is
left behind and the answer is if 95% is
within this range then 5% is outside
that range but 5% is outside and there
are two pieces that are five that make
up the 5% then clearly each of the
pieces is going to be 2.5%
right it's half of that five so now you
can see whether the 97.5 number comes
from it comes from including all of
these scores here right if you had some
light globe and it had a Zed score of
exactly two then it's going to be ninety
seven point five percent along in terms
of this distribution
okay so now we know where the 97.5 comes
from what we need to say is well how do
I use that to actually answer this
question right well I can imagine that
there is a specific light bulb that has
exactly five thousand hours lifespans so
therefore I can say based on this work
that I've done to understand the normal
distribution I can say that five
thousand hour like lab has a z-score of
exactly - okay so I can write from this
equation how do I work out a Zen score
well again the formula data sheet will
help you do a formula right there that
the dead score is X minus X bar on s
remember what this means X is the actual
score of your particular light globe
right now there's the mean lifetime
which is the thing we're trying to work
out there's your standard deviation
okay so just carrying on over here
because I have more room this like low
which has five thousand hours which
lasts for five thousand hours has a
z-score of 2 so that's what I'm gonna
write instead of Zed its lifespan is
five thousand I don't know what the mean
is I'm going to find that out in a
second and the standard deviation has
been provided to me in the question so
you can see here this is all I need this
is the equation which will tell me the
mean I just need to rearrange this do a
little bit of algebra I'll multiply both
sides by 170 which leaves me with this
I'll add X bar to both sides and I'll
also subtract 340 from both sides which
leaves me with four thousand six hundred
and sixty that's the number of hours
that it lasts okay so just to review how
did I go through this question well I
knew that I had to use all of this
information here but how am I going to
use it the big clue for me in terms of
what started me off my working was this
percentage right that instantly told me
I'm gonna have to do something with
z-scores even though the question never
says z-score when you are trying to work
out some percentage of the population
and you know the proportion that is
permitted then
you're gonna have to say well this
number of standard deviations away this
z-score and negative 1 to 1 will give me
this negative 2 2 2 will give me this
and you work out which number is
appropriate so that was the first big
clue that's got me started then I had to
work out well how do I get 97.5%
exactly how far away will I have to go
well that's how I had to think about
each step I use the formula data sheet
to help me remember what the actual
numbers were and you can see that here
is ninety seven point five percent of
all of the like loads and then will last
up to everyone in this group will last
up to five thousand hours then finally I
used the z-score formula here and I
slotted in all the information which
came from the question namely the 5000
and 170 and also from my my logic my
inference the to working out how far the
population could go so this is one of
the ways you would dissect a question to
do with the normal distribution is a bit
tough but that's why it's um I think
it's actually the last part of a long
multi-part question so that's why it
takes a little more brain work to come
up with the answer